hello sports fans I am here with Nick
and Ramon from sunny San Diego studios
how are you guys pretty good fabulous
what are we looking at ten you guys
brought MLB the show 2015 which is
coming out just about a week March 31st
so two weeks okay two weeks yeah so last
year was the first year that it was on
PlayStation 4 a big deal for you know
the show and you guys are going to show
us some of the new stuff that the game
has coming up for this year yeah what do
we what are we looking at the first
thing we're gonna show you is what
happens when you first install MLB 15
the show
and you played MLB 14 the show which is
our royalty programming let Nick take it
away yeah so we're doing this thing
called the universal rewards so we
brought a couple screenshots so when you
first enter the game first thing you're
gonna see is you're gonna get a bunch of
stuff basically with our new Universal
rewards feature where we're showering
you with items that you'll be able to
use throughout the game we've developed
a bunch of these new items you got
equipment we got nine new licensed
partners this year Nikes one of them
they're Under Armour Rawlings Wilson we
got every essential representative in
cleats bagging gloves
fielding gloves and bats for that
authentic experience exactly yeah we
thought we wanted to do it for years so
we're pretty psyched about that and then
you'll also be getting cards we got this
little stamp system going on in the
bottom where every day you log in to get
stamping any a free pack after nine
stamps like we like sandwiches at the
studio so then yeah I mean so one of the
cards actually do once you unlock those
like what can players do with them yeah
just for collecting uh no so we have a
mode called Diamond Dynasty which is you
know fantasy card collecting mode where
you build like a fantasy team of players
so you'll be collecting these cards no
matter where you play even if you're
playing like our our road to the show
mode franchise mode you'll be collecting
all sorts of different stuff and
franchise mode we got a new feature
where you can partner with like a brand
and they'll sponsor your team and
depending on what stats your you're
getting in game you'll earn an extra
budget to spend on your team and stuff
will they ever drop you for playing like
crap you'll get what you get
look at budget but yeah they won't ever
drop you it's basically like an item
that you can just swap in and out
whenever you want to like partner up
that'll you'll see it on when you go in
Game two it'll be represented in like
the in-game on-screen displays it'll
show like you know a Nike switch down in
the bottom right of your news ticker
what you know stuff like that yeah we're
in the road to the show you get you get
equipment so we basically have this
equipment system where it's it's pretty
RPG and you know inspired you you equip
this stuff on your player and it's
batting glove slot is glove slot and
there's three qualities of each each
brand in each item slot so you know you
could get like really good Nike shoes
ridiculously good Nike shoes and those
will actually make your player faster
just like kind of and what's awesome
about Universal rewards and the cards is
even if you're getting stuff that you
don't want to use you can still use it
to get stuff that you do play because
like we hear that some people are only
play road to the show and I never play
franchise well you're giving me these
sponsorships and franchise that I'll
never use well you can put those on a
community marketplace and sell them for
stuff to use and Road to the show oh and
if you get stuff you don't want yeah you
can exchange them on the marketplace and
purchase something that you can yeah
that's great so we're in a game here I'm
gonna try not to suck I'm also gonna try
try which is not popped up Ramon is I
think you're like it's really really bad
it's not that bad but so it's nervous
yeah so we've done a lot of stuff to the
game this year and we'll talk about
gameplay first gameplays King gameplays
everything and this year we've done the
most in the game play Ram and we've ever
done in any other year and that starts
with one is we have enhanced ball
physics we don't have set our fly balls
we're kind of hanging too much and we
weren't seeing enough doubles and
triples in the game yeah so what we've
done is we've reworked the code and we
have our exit velocity for fastball
we've changed it so now balls get to the
precipice a lot faster which means
they'll hit the ground fairs
well gotcha so guys won't be as uh so
you won't catch a lot of those easy fly
balls and some of them drop in and give
you those more doubles and triples what
we've also done is we've relooked at our
speed paradigm across the board and
change basically the way the game works
base stealers are faster than they used
to be like a really fast guys in the
game they're faster than they've always
been everybody else's may be a little
bit slower mouth fielders in general
they're a little bit slower but we've
also done is one of the major complaints
we've always heard was oh the computer
always little knows where the balls in
the land so we have this thing called
advanced routes the ball where the
computer doesn't quite know exactly
where the ball is gonna land and it also
varies under if you're using a gold
Glover or not somebody's really good so
guys won't take straight beat lines to
the ball anymore they'll take more
realistic rounding paths and that has a
big effect on the game maybe it's about
that she would have caught in last
year's game now he won't catch it or
maybe he does catch it but he catches it
an angle to where he can't get a great
throw off and maybe you take second at a
curve it's interesting like people think
of simulation games as being very
difficult by nature and it sounds like
you guys have made it more fun but also
more difficult in a way yeah yeah it's
about our game does have a reputation
for being difficult but it is a we do
pride ourselves as a baseball simulation
and that's mainly because in baseball
you know if you fail seven out of ten
times you're one of the best players in
baseball sure so it is naturally
inherent to baseball but yeah it's a
it's nuts it's not too hard I feel like
a lot of people you know especially in
sports games they have the pride factor
I know I have it we're like even if I
pick up a game for the first time I got
to put it on like you know all-star
difficulty level and I play a lot of
games good but and our game will punish
you if you try to skip ahead
we've also added over 700 new gameplay
animations we've completely redone our
tax system which you'll notice all the
time now our tags match up the guys
glove he actually is trying to touch a
body part instead of just trying to tag
him out sure we've also done this thing
is when you're playing we've added 70
new third out animation so when guys get
that third out they'll make a nice
player they'll point it around back
towards the dugout and that's something
that we've added this year we've also
reworked basically all of our
hitting difficulties trying to balance
everything out we've made a couple
methods a little bit harder like me the
pitching is a little bit harder this
year I was looking around yeah which is
what you're looking at me to pitching
being a little bit easier we also have
this new feature called quick shifts so
after he throws this pitch if he doesn't
strike them out fresh is on nikto so we
can't show you quickly can make out
maybe we'll show you quickly a third out
a lot of people thing about sports game
just kind of just the same game every
year with new rosters but you guys are
really just going to tell on this thing
no yeah we pride ourselves every year we
we really hammer it and we keep we keep
and really good touch with our user base
we think we're always trying to trying
to give them what they want
and yeah we we work really hard every
year to make to make a really compelling
new title I mean that's our job right is
to convince people that this year's game
is much better than last year's game
right and I think people trust us that
we do that we we definitely pump out a
lot of new features I mean more than
more than we can ever even talk about if
you go to our website we always put out
a huge feature list and it's it's
intense it's really like I'll take you a
while to read yeah the Patrol always try
to cuz that's the number one goal every
year for any sports franchise it's to
make the person not think oh it's just a
roster update right we're always trying
to do compelling features new ways to
play the game to kind of counteract that
and I need to get a base hit here you
can feel it too I mean wouldn't this
year like anybody who's played last
year's game I think they'll genuinely
feel it when they play this game I mean
not even just graphically or a game
looks a lot better I mean we took a huge
leap last year first year on ps4 and
this year I'm really impressed with what
our graphics guys have done they've
really I mean everything every aspect of
graphics is vastly improved this year
every what I understand the lighting in
particular has been tweaked quite a bit
can you talk a little bit about that
sure so what our graphics team tasks
themselves with this year was a few
things one was this do we have this new
tech called color matching and what this
tech allows us to do it allows every
artist to go to mlb.com pull up Kansas
City Royals Stadium find the perfect
daygame in June with no clouds in the
sky and we'll pause that game and what
they'll do is they'll grab a swatch of
the grass color from that game and
they'll pull it into this program and it
immediately gets transferred to the game
okay and we do that in three different
areas we do that for grass color so
every MLB stadium has their own unique
grass color pool from real mlb.com
footage we do it for dirt color as well
so all 30 stations have their own unique
dirt color and we've also used this
technology and our player skin tones
what the feature we call it features
cause player skin tone realism and all
of our games in the past we've had seven
skin tones that we've have to group over
seven hundred and great players ended up
looking constantly
yeah so with this player skin tone
matching which we're doing the same
thing we do with the stadiums we
basically pull up a screen shot probably
from spring training of them getting it
getting their head scans we take a
little blocks from the cheek and we give
them their own unique skin tone so now
every major league player in the game
has his own unique skin tone it's pulled
from real photos of him in real life
that's great and it adds a lot to the
game some other things that we've done
and this is a big one is distinct on
seasonal Sun and shadows the way our Sun
and shadows have always worked in MLB
the show was the Sun was static it would
always move in the same degree no matter
where it was April May June July August
September we all know that's not how
things work in real life the Sun and
shadows in April in Fenway is much
different than the Sun and shadows in
June and July and so you'll see that
you'll see the Sun will start in one
position and it'll start to rotate
shadows will creep more onto the field
and it just adds a lot of life to the
statements that we just didn't have last
year so people are really going to enjoy
playing all these iconic stadiums
throughout the year and different times
of day to see how the Sun and shadows
react and you can see it's an exhibition
exhibition mode we allow you to pick the
month we've never allowed you to do that
because it wouldn't have done anything
right so we allow you pick the month and
the time of day so you can see the
different Sun positions and the shadows
moving across the field
awesome so from what I understand you
can also bring some save data from last
year's game into this yes so you do
things you do saves this feature that
noticed
what's game has over the first
development team to be able to crack
that code and what you do saves allows
you to do is carry on your franchise
season or Road to the show save files
from MLB 14 and 15 so in essence you
just never have to start over that's
something that people have always asked
for I create this role to the show guy I
get to the majors and then the next MLB
the show come out and have to start over
well I don't want to start over anymore
now we've been we've given you that
ability and it works very simple if you
play it MLB 14 the show you just keep
that safe out on your hard drive don't
delete it when you buy MLB 15 it's
really simple you're gonna roll to the
show
once you pressure out the show you'll
see this new option that says continue
from MLB 14 you press that option
we recognize that save file and you pick
up right where you left off right and if
you are moving to PlayStation 4 for the
first time and you were playing on Vita
or ps3 last year you can still bring
that save file over one extra step so
let's say you bought the PlayStation
Vita version last year and you're
upgrading the PlayStation 4 so to use
your do you say is what you want to do
is take your PlayStation Vita save file
upload it to the cloud and download it
from the cloud onto your Playstation 4
and the PlayStation 4 will recognize
that save file and you can continue from
where you start off seems like there's
every incentive for people who played
last year to pick up this away oh yeah
exactly and we get we get a lot of
questions all the time about you to say
is like well what about all the new
features there in game do I get those
yes you get all the new features if
you're using a year do you save from
franchise and you're a Dodgers fan last
year we didn't have licensed equipment
this year we do so if you use the year
to save file we're gonna update all of
the real MLB players to have the
licensed equipment that they're supposed
to wear same things with face scans if a
guy has a new face game you're gonna get
that new face scan our new GM goals
contracts feature in franchise mode
you're opted in to that brand new
feature the same thing with rode to the
show and licensed equipment you're opted
in to those new features so you're able
to carry on that old save if you still
get all the new stuff in there will be
15 yeah that's wonderful
and do we haven't base it yet no we
don't
don't go to Reginald hitting this is a
new hitting feature we have this year
maybe I'll be able to get a base hit
with this right so where you aiming
wasn't aiming anywhere I just want it so
we it's it's a it's an augment of our
timing hitting where it's just timing
specific you don't have to worry about
put it using our what we call our plate
coverage indicator yes who get the ball
you said to worry about timing but you
can influence where you want to hit it
by by using the left stick and that's so
if I want everyone in the air I'll press
up
I actually let's see if we can pull one
yeah and hold it so often people are
intimidated to kind of get into the
sports games if they like haven't played
this on time yeah because they think I
mean everyone's going to be so much
better than me or maybe the game has
changed so much and gotten so in-depth
that it's not gonna be what I you know
what I would hope to be able to get into
but you guys have implemented a bunch of
stuff to kind of ease that process yeah
we have we have beginner mode when you
first load the game we ask you do you
play a lot of games or do you not play
and if you choose well I kind of don't
play a lot of games we default the game
to the more easier settings you're on
timing hitting which is actually the
most popular heating method and you're
on classic pitching and we turn on auto
fielding for you so all you have to
worry about is the hitting and pitching
ask aspects of the game and once you get
those down then you can turn on turn off
auto filled and you can start to learn
how to feel so we have different
mechanisms in the game to help new users
to get more acclimated we also have a
tips option that's defaulted on at the
bottom of the screen will constantly
show you little tips and hints
throughout the game of things that's
going on so you'll know how to do all
the different mechanics and can help you
show how is the the commentary evolved I
can't imagine how much work goes into
that because you guys have to record
dialogue for like any possible scenario
with every player I imagine there's
absolutely tons right so it's twe
attacked it to fold this year there's
over 1700 new lines of play-by-play
commentary is what we've also done is
we've changed how Matt calls different
things let in last year's game or any
other MLB to show it was gonna be a home
run
Matt will call it as a home
we kind of give it away now those calls
are more dynamic so Matt will get really
excited about a deep flop on it looks
like it's gonna get out but then
somebody catches it and you're like oh I
I kind of got fooled that's the way
Matt's talking about we call double
plays differently now we do more dynamic
calls around the strike zone
but the biggest thing we've done in the
commentary is our new inside the show
new sweet
it's a radio show that plays and wrote
to the show and in franchise mode and
what we've noticed is and one of the
biggest complaints we've always heard
about is throughout the season I know
what's going on with my player and my
team but I'm kind of lost about what's
going on sure and so what inside the
show radio new sweet does is it gives
you a radio show every single day at the
end of every game and tells you what's
going on in the league the first thing
the radio show always talks about is
your team or your guy on the road to the
show so if you play the game you went 4
for 5 with Andrew McCutchen he's gonna
talk about that but what you also hear
you're gonna hear a lot of dynamic stuff
let's say a guy hits it's 5,000 career
home run you're gonna hear about that
you're gonna hear about the playoff race
if there are any trades the radio shows
are going to talk about the trade so
nothing's canned in the radio show it's
all dynamic you're gonna hear new stuff
all the time
so every time you kick off that radio
show you're gonna hear something
different
what's another cool thing about the
radio show is you spend about half
amount of time playing games as you do
in the front end so it's like a
one-to-one thing so you're spending all
this time in the front end doing lineups
making trades and nothing's going on
right you kick off a radio show and then
you can go and do all that stuff and
still get a radio show on the background
and we think that adds a lot of life and
depth and the franchise and role to the
show this year yeah that sounds really
cool is there how much does does this
game connect to the actual baseball
season in real life like are there any
things that update or yeah play around
with that yeah we have a feature called
the show live which basically we take in
a direct feed from the MLB mlb.com it's
the same feed that they use to update
their scores okay and we update the
scores actively in our game and then you
can go in and if you want to play a game
from that's happening right now or today
you can go and jump in and they'll have
those updated lineups up to the
stuff it's also yeah we also do roster
updates weekly to make sure that we're
following you know what's happening and
really at call ups and downs any trades
anything that happens in free agency if
even players you know if they're if
they're on a tear you'll see that
reflected in how good they are in our
game I'm sure you can also turn that off
if you don't want to be disturbed yeah
yeah I mean you you can always keep your
old you know launch day rosters or your
custom rosters the more I think so bring
up the defensive quick shifts down d-pad
so this is another new feature the one
our designers create it's called quick
shifts you used to have to pause the
game go on a defensive shifts inside it
so let's say this guy's the extreme pull
hitter and you just want to say for this
at-bat I just want to go extreme and
it's what we've done have you taken the
most common shifts and we just thrown
them here in this quick shift menu and
it's just a much faster way to do
defensive shifts because no baseball
there's a lot of strategy in baseball so
that's another way you can get quick
shifts what we've also done is there
wasn't a way that you could see your
pitches pitch count if you weren't
pitching so if you hit left on the d-pad
you can always see the total pitch count
and pitch your energy for both pitches
on the mound
even when the other guy is not even on
the mountain pitching that's been a very
much requested thing and so another
thing to try to show new players I play
game dances tips down at the bottom
right just hit tips and it shows you all
the different quick meetings that we
have in the game and I'm gonna give up
home run is there any integration with
the PlayStation camera at all like any
voice commands I'm trying to imagine how
that would even fit in but I can't so
listen Asian cameras is an awesome tool
we're thinking of creative ways to use
it
but an MLB 15 we are not using a
PlayStation camera it hurt us but we do
have some ideas we've had we've
definitely talked about them they're all
this really weird and spirits we all saw
how well face mapping work and some
sports games last yeah so it's you know
and ball boys actually catch the balls
now so the crowd the crowd actually
catch fly balls and homeland next-gen
Bulbul next evolve because where they
catch the they actually catch the balls
can I get him nope
what have you guys done to the crowds at
all have they changed like in terms of
their behaviors or the models at all one
of the biggest things we've done is we
have accurate crowd placement in most
games like there are a couple of
stadiums and teams like Boston
Philadelphia that sell out games
unfortunately a whole baseball fan bases
aren't that crazy so what you'll see is
the cheap seats most of the time will be
empty but Kansas City has a rabid fan
base and the plan against Pittsburgh so
it's it's pretty cool yeah but yeah you
can see a little sparkle it's more full
down by the field with it's not young
field so in the field level you'll see
it'll be all full but as you start to go
out to the cheap seats you'll start to
see it get a little bit no-man's land
without a lot of people but it also
depends upon the team and the time of
year like if you're in the playoff race
obviously they're going to be more
people in the state last year was the
first year for ps4 so we
really built out the crowd and you got
people holding signs doing presentations
like gets more involved hey is it new
this year that they can actually catch
the balls yeah yeah what about like the
the clothing they wear like if it's a
night game yeah here in giant stadium
like that's Jack it's pretty cold Vegas
yet having jackets like that next to
those physics though I'm also curious
about the sort of legacy player know you
were telling me about her yeah yeah it's
the road to the show yeah it's you play
as one player you create your own custom
guy you start in the minors it's you
know it's I think by far our most
popular mode and and you build them up
you play you try to make the majors you
so you train them up train his skills he
gets progressively better you deal with
his contract negotiations and stuff like
that all the way up and then the new one
of the big new features we added that we
talked about earlier was that equipment
feature where you get to like fly you
acquire this equipment and you shoot
them up you guys bring back a lot of
legendary players as well from the past
we yeah we got a partnership with the
MLB Alumni Association so we got one
iconic alumni player from each team or
legends and yeah there's a hole you can
use you can use them in the in the
offline modes like whatever you want but
you gotta collect the card they're
special legends which is awesome it's a
throw it like looks like the card Shara
we're partnered with tops to make it
make them get the actual assets so it's
totally nostalgic I I remember a lot of
those cards its Babe Ruth on both the
Red Sox and the Yankees the Red Sox Ted
Williams of course
oh sure muffin yeah like a hit a bomb a
break this time you can find those
legend cards in in packs or if you
collect a team you can collect enough
players in the team you'll actually
unlock access to that
what do you do for sort of the the more
recent additions to the league like how
far back to some of those players go
well so we like is that Andres Galarraga
the oh we're covering all eras in terms
of the legends like I think our most
recent legend might be like I think the
dire back Steve Finley you know he was
pretty local or a pretty recent guy we
have will the thrill' Clark you know San
Francisco and but then yeah it goes way
back Ted Williams and I do they're out
near the uniform mismatch
we do that we have throat like they
don't actually wear different uniforms
on the team that they plan but we do
have our throwback uniforms from us to
our games and in the in diamond dynasty
mode you get to like create your own
uniform your own custom uniform we have
I mean for it's a layer based seriously
robust logo creator and Jersey creator
it's it's best-in-class for sure we have
some videos online some people do some
crazy super realistic people much better
at art than me so I think there's just a
whole lot to play with yeah just outside
of you know a standard exhibition game
or there's a lot a lot of depth got a
different flavors for everybody you just
want to play one-off games and do that
if you want to do a deep franchise mode
you can do that some one thing we
haven't talked about is the editions
that we made to franchise mode this was
a really important year for us and like
every year we try to focus on you know
either Roadshow franchise movies to get
a lot of new features and she has
franchises turn so we've done is in the
past once you pick the team you were
stuck with that team there was no way if
you get fired or get other offers now we
have this new feature called gym goals
and contracts so once you start a team
once you pick a team you start a
three-year contract with that team and
you'll have you have a yearly goal and a
three-year contract goal if you get both
of those goals you're either one get to
be up with the team or you'll get better
offers so let's say you start with
houston astros and you get them over 500
for two or three years and maybe that's
a goal maybe you get a better offer
maybe coach I don't know the Giants or
the Cincinnati Reds and it's a really
cool feature because it now allows you
to move around in franchise and not just
be locked to that one team oh that's
great
there's some other very much requested
features like trade fine do we have a
trade finder we've completely rewritten
our trade logic to make it more
realistic what else that we've done it
minor league contract yeah we have a
minor league contract you know like
there's just so many little things to
that we worry about in the simulation
aspect of a game every year trying to
improve and make it better there's a lot
of things like we contract logic is a
big deal right I'm a baseball game nerd
and it's big it's like yeah one accurate
contracts but to a lot of people it's
like you know and some people it's the
graphics are their own they're all about
the graphics I'm sure you guys have like
the light-hearted features like homerun
Derby
oh yeah we have a new homeowner before
Matt - yeah they changed the format limo
B so we reflect that we have an online
homerun Derby which is really fun oh
that's cool you all like you know it
could be eight people playing
simultaneously hitting home runs and you
see like the Ray the ribbons go off you
see everybody else's hits yours
so I'm sure for the online stuff it's
all processed locally and and sent to
the server because it'd be pretty hard
to sync up those frames given how strict
the timing is for getting a hit if it
was done in the silver like when we when
in terms of online home run derby
actually you don't actually have to we
kind of cheat because you all you have
to know is the ball path so you don't
actually have to send that much across
okay online it's really it's really
straightforward you just have to know
where the ball isn't send the ball
coordinates okay that's the problem
I'm gonna have to get some money in the
pool we also have this this feature that
is made last year called community
challenges where oh oh
host community the challenges is like
you're you're sort of like an perfect
like a play create share type feature
where you get to create whatever
scenario you want with whatever teams
you want and and put it up and other
players can go try it and like they can
actually stay in the earn currency to go
buy packs with and stuff if they pass it
yes it's pretty cool it's competitive
each one has their own leaderboard
there's just yeah like there's a lot for
for anybody who wants to it doesn't
matter what you're looking for we have
it that's like what you know does it
mean it's inherit to sports games you
get a lot of different demographics
people you got your your RPG players you
know who likes sports you got your
simulation and like sort of team
management players of like sports you
got people who are creative artistically
and we want to cater to anybody
yeah yeah get some right up in the
bullpen because it's only the fourth
it's falling apart though it is it is so
far the stakes are made a little bit so
mouth is it is you know how many people
didn't know this feature was in the game
and what a mouth is it does allows you
go and talk to your pitcher and
hopefully calm down at the right time
he'll get a confidence vote wissy which
you got if you do it at the wrong time
he could actually take a confidence hit
me that once per inning per pitcher if
you do it twice you've got that yang
come on oh that's a problem it didn't
work so is there any advantage to not
doing it once per inning just to gain
that little boost is it or is it just
the risk that it might go down well if
you do it just to do it like it's gonna
go down all right like pitches are
creatures of habit and if they see the
pitching coach and manager Walker what's
wrong with you like what am I like why
are you out here you're doing fine so
yeah if you just burned it just to burn
that he would definitely take confidence
here I'm very sensitive players those
pitchers yes and he's like I'm out
he's gotta get us out of here Nick's
gotta get through these runs back nope
you got a hit party going on and as a
new feature called oh nice he tested it
oh so another thing you can see is the
season of Sun and shadows working here
when right I went to the fifth inning
and the game started it was daylight
right and now it's starting to get a
little bit darker the lights are
starting to come on and you're starting
to see how the field will look
differently in the fourth and fifth
inning the will and the first thing and
pin it on the Sun position and if the
lights are on
oh no and now it's dust no way that's a
good that's a trap a three no all right
so I think we are going to let you guys
get back to work on this game because it
sounds like you got a lot of work maybe
but you know what I don't actually play
no sports games but I'm intrigued by
this because it sounds like there's a
lot of stuff in there beyond just the
hardcore simulation that so many people
expect thanks for sitting down with us
today thanks for having us and this
coming out March 31st yeah PlayStation 3
PlayStation Vita and PlayStation 4 all
right Ross platform saves you can play
all of them same save file the same if
you want to buy it twice you know take
it on the bus all right thanks for
watching everybody this is Emily the
show 2015 stay tuned and gamespot.com
for more sports coverage
you